going all the way back to how he got
started in the 70s the influence he had
there's got to be people that either
trained him to do what he did in the 90s
2000 or influenced them negatively and
taught him some bad habits a lot of
times in business will bring an agent
that comes from another company that
company if they do forgeries because
that guy learned some of those habits at
a different company before they brought
it you know how did you learn how to do
this well when I used to do mortgage it
was called creative financing oh my God
we don't do that that's not the right
way of doing business so how do you
yourself when you look at somebody like
this someone must have taught him these
bad habits right so it looks to me that
it was somewhere around the time uh he
went to Bear Stearns which was his first
uh really entry into the financial world
because you know as I just mentioned
earlier most people think of epson as a
sex criminal based on my research he
stressed as much a financial criminal as
a SSX criminal
um but in the book I try and go even
further back to that in pursuit of you
know where this intelligence tie may
have originally started and and it you
know he was apparently had a British
royal family connection as as early as
the early 70s like 1971 when he was you
know in his 20s
um you know he was supposed to be
backpacking in Europe there's some weird
Mystique around that particular uh trip
that I know in in the book
um but after that he you know went to
the Dalton school which I think some
people that looked into the case you
know after his his second arrest are
probably familiar with because the the
man that hired him there uh who is the
the Headmaster of Dalton at the time was
William Barr's father Donald Barr and
Bill Barr is in the yeah the two-time
Attorney General yes and his father was
a former uh a veteran of the office of
strategic Services which is a precursor
to the CIA and then he went to Colombia
and was sort of a talent scout I guess
in a sense uh because he he ran a lot of
um programs at Columbia focusing on
talented high schoolers and uh it's very
possible that Epstein was a very gifted
high schooler in the New York area he
graduated high school very young he went
to the Interlochen Academy of Arts
um and was a very talented uh teenager
so it's very possible he may have met
Donald Barr that way
but Donald Barr for whatever reason
hires him to go to the Dalton school and
according to you know former students
quoted by the New York Times he showed a
weird interest in partying uh with
underage kids even then and wanted to
drink and some claim they hit on him and
all this stuff and other people said
that was normal at the Dalton school
um and all of that and the reason for
him leaving isn't quite clear but he was
sort of head hunted there by Alan
Greenberg of bear Stearns and went um
and and joined that particular bank and
Alan Greenberg just a couple years after
he brought Epstein into bear Stearns
became the head of bear Stearns
um so Epstein was sort of from what I
understand seeing his mentor was
basically Greenberg and Greenberg goes
to the top of the bank and so obviously
that helps Epstein's career he you know
climbs the ladder pretty rapidly rapidly
there and then starts working um first
with some of their Elite clientele the
identities of which we don't exactly
know but based on the circumstances
under which he left it was related to an
SEC investigation focusing on insider
trading of the bronfman family comp
company Seagrams I believe yeah so it
seems like Edgar brownfman he may have
been involved in advising him on some
things and what he was apparently well
known for and talented in at Bear
Stearns was amazing people about tax law
so there may have been some sort of tax
evasion stuff or something I mean he
left under rather murky circumstances
and there's a lot of you know differing
opinions coming out of there but in
looking at the particular Seagram's
insider trading stuff and that the SEC
was tipped off that Epstein knew
something about it in Epstein leaves so
there's no blowback for the bank because
at this point right his
um his mentors the head of of the bank
that could obviously have impacts all
the way up at Bear Stearns right and
another thing that's interesting is just
a couple uh around that same time uh the
who the person who had been the legal
counsel for Bear Stearns most of the
time that Epstein was working for that
bank became CIA director under Reagan
Bill Casey
so these links by the way if you go on
Donald Barr because we went through that
very quickly Bill Barr's father Donald
Barr okay so that's Donald Barr when
when he was uh uh at Dalton to just to
kind of put perspective put and put into
perspective for the audience how big of
a deal is the school uh Dalton
I understand it's kind of one of the you
know I'm not from New York City and I've
never been there so you know I don't
have like an Insider understanding
necessarily of that but from what I
understand a lot of you know Elite
wealthy people who went to the school
send their children there yeah and and
when when he hired uh uh Epstein to
become a professor teaching mathematics
this is a guy that's never had a degree
before right like Epstein never got it
he would have not been eligible as I
understand it to even teach in public
school in New York how does that make
any sense for him to get a job even
though he's never had anything before
right so Donald Barr apparently hired
unconventional teachers and was known
for this right but he actually left by
the time Epstein started hiring
decisions were apparently made in the
spring in that summer Donald Barr left
after having made those hiring decisions
so during most of Epstein's time there
it was another Headmaster and from what
I understand Donald Barr's um him
leaving the Dalton school was rather
acrimonious like he was sort of forced
out it seems by uh Angry parents and
some angry teachers it yeah so
apparently he was he was there till what
summer of 94 is when I'm when you're
forcing me to do so much research it's
not even funny I think it's like 74. 74
yeah that's in summer 74 and then
Epstein started working months prior to
that right like in 73 teaching physics
teaching physics and you you don't have
a four-year degree that that's that's
that's incredibly weird to me no it's
weird that he was hired considering that
he couldn't even have taught at public
school is this Epstein or Bill Barr's
father we're talking about it so so um
well who is teaching no no Donald
Epstein got it but Epstein didn't have a
four-year degree to teach anything but
even yeah he didn't graduate from
undergraduate yeah so so just think
about and then by the way the one thing
that's also pretty weird with this whole
connection is Donald Barr wrote a book
uh space relations yes space relations a
public publish a science fiction novel
that contained several prominent
references to and descriptions of rape
and sexual slavery exact slavery that's
true and that was published shortly
after he left the Dalton school so
there's a weird mix here right but I
mean you can't make any direct
connection necessarily but given
everything else we're talking about
about Epstein intelligence the sex
crimes all of that it starts to look
kind of you know weird you know this far
back but you know obviously over time it
gets can you can you do me a favor and
just pull up the following pull up the
text I just sent you and the only reason
I'm showing this is because I know the
folks at YouTube value Snopes because
they want things to be uh uh uh looked
at and you know how if you can pull that
up but while you're doing that the the
strange part of the story is the fact
that the person that ends up putting
Epstein in jail is Donald Barr's son
William Barr well at this exact time
when Donald Barr is hires Jeffrey
Epstein and all of this is going on at
the Dalton School William Barr is
already at the CIA William Barr is
already at the CIA that's where he
started his career pretty much in 73-74
I think it was after well so Epstein I
think it started in 74 so as I mentioned
earlier Donald Barr made hiring
decisions in the spring leaves that
summer and then Epstein starts that fall
semester and in the same period of time
William Barr's already associated with
the CIA so for the folks at YouTube and
others here's Snopes okay so we we're
fact checking this did Bill Barr's
father Mentor Jeffrey Epstein and write
a bizarre novel okay so if I can comment
on that yeah we're not talking I didn't
say anything right now we haven't said
anything about there being a mentor
really sure it was a hiring decision
right so a lot of times with these fact
check sites they'll put in like oh there
was no Mentor relationship and then they
debunked the whole thing but Donald Barr
did write a bizarre novel yeah and he
did hire Jeffrey Epstein can you pull up
a little bit hang on hang on but let's
see what these guys are saying because
these guys people follow these guys
mostly fall so go up go up go up go up
go up go up so okay down at the top let
me read that one first uh claim Donald
Barr father of U.S general Bill Barr
hired Jeffrey Epstein as a teacher
served as his mentor and wrote a novel
about men raping teenage girls okay go
to the bottom mostly false what's true
Donald Barr was Headmaster of Dalton
School in New York until the summer of
74 and 74 Epstein began working as a
math and physics professor at the school
in 1973 Barr published a science fiction
novel that contained several prominent
references to and the scrimshev's rape
and sexual slavery what's false is
Dalton is not an all-girl school and was
not so when Epstein worked there to
claim that bar was Epstein's Mentor
appears to be more than an idol uh
speculations unsupported by evidence
bars and novel does not celebrate
slavery or sexual violence uh against
underage girls and in one instance the
protagonist brutal murders another
character to avenge the rape of a
teenage girl
right so I wasn't familiar with the date
of the the publication of the book but I
knew it was around the the ballpark you
know the same time that he's um you know
hiring Epstein so I didn't know it was
it was earlier but I've never heard the
claim that it was an all-girl school as
far as I understand it was it's just
this time I mean who would want to write
a book like this genders but I mean I so
I haven't read the book I've only read
parts of it but from what I understand
there is like a sex slavery thing but
not necessarily for like minors right
but it is an odd book to be sure so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]